hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another update of my Twitter $10,000
challenge the idea here is to make ten
thousand dollars in new business only
coming from Twitter as my marketing
mechanism so quick recap to date I have
made twenty five hundred dollars with a
client with a project that is currently
happening right now and that may lead to
more business in the future still have
to be determined but that's ongoing so
that's great and I just landed a new
client that found me again through
Twitter this one is fifteen hundred
dollars and that's going to add to our
total so new client came in this is just
a text from the email that came in so my
client is Leslie again they my clients
don't seem to like being named in the
videos because I don't think they like
people knowing how much they're paying
me for whatever reason so this is an
email that came in I asked how she found
me and she said we've always want to
look at on Twitter and in the media to
see who's active in the SMB space I
believe we saw you on twitter and I look
at your website best Leslie so the
difference in my pricing model typically
I'll create a blog post or I'll join
some kind of event that they're having
and i usually charge twenty-five hundred
dollars per engagement sometimes if it's
not going to take me a lot of time and
there's no promotion so don't have to
put it to my newsletter list or do much
on twitter or facebook then i charge
$1,500 usually clients like the extra
promotion and the boost that that i give
them so they spend twenty-five hundred
but this new client is the first time
working with them we've booked the date
and they're paying me 15 i knows i'm not
going to the promotional boost for them
so today we've got our 2500 from before
we've got our 1500 that's new and so
total we've made four thousand dollars
only coming from twitter and we'll see
how it goes again a quick overview of
what i'm doing what my strategy is to
get people in from Twitter this is a
project that we started with with the
Shawn Moffitt Shawn Moffitt is a expert
here in Toronto
and he's a very active Twitter user so
the couple things I do there's three
main things that I do that I'm going to
share with you and maybe you can apply
it to your business as well we find them
see the tweets champion and I'll go to
my own Twitter account to show you kind
of stuff I'm doing there we go so the
first thing is I made a list of
different brands I guess who are
potential customers or her potential
influencers who I want to recognize and
thank them for their contribution and
also let them know about me because I
may not have known who I am or at least
keep me on top of their radar screen so
i created this page and every day what I
do is I'll pull out a list 11 contact
and I'll tweet this out and I'll
recognize them as a small business
champion of the day and that's a nice
ego boost and I almost always get a
response back to say thank you I'm not a
hard sales pitch guy so I'm not
responding saying you're welcome I think
we should work together I'm basically
leaving them to look at my profile and
see if they see an opportunity to
potentially work together so that's one
thing i do almost every day the other
thing i do oh this is not loading up
right now something wrong with the
twitter api but that's okay i'll pull in
some contacts so these are people who
are in the SMB space or potential
customers or potential connectors and
we're not seeing it right now but
typically what this shows is their most
recent tweets and so it allows me an
opportunity to respond to them and I
used to have it than I had everybody I
had 90 contacts and I made a list of and
i responded to a portion of that so 18
people every day it got to be a little
too taxing on my time I'm and so now
we'll only do a couple of them every day
so whatever shows up it's random now
I'll just respond to a few of them the
biggest driver though I think of the
business has been through my own Twitter
account and posting content that is of
interest to the SMB community so that
people i'm targeting our brands who want
celta entrepreneurs and so I'm providing
a lot of information on my Twitter
account that helps entrepreneurs and so
while posting so this is my live feed
here i'll post things you know some
quotes that might be interesting some
you know fun pictures that i find
interesting or inspiring you know some
again some quotes that link to my
facebook page maybe it links to my
website and basically try to provide a
lot of value at content videos etc that
entrepreneur interested in and if you
look at what Leslie wrote to me she said
we're always along a lookout on Twitter
and in the media see who's active in the
SMB space and so you know companies are
looking to hire people like you they
want to see that you're an expert in
that you are very active in your space
so that when they you know are looking
for that person to hire they're going to
go for you and so I think the biggest
driver so far has been me posting
content that is high value add to my
readers and people are finding me
through that content i also have a bio
which you can obviously do with your own
Twitter account I say that I help
entrepreneurs but I also write that I
help brands connect with the
entrepreneur and so if your brand coming
to my page most of people who visit my
Twitter account our entrepreneurs
looking for inspiration quality content
and some of them will be the brains and
so I mentioned that as well that there's
an opportunity for brands to help
connect so that's what I'm doing again
so far the total is four thousand
dollars to date everything is coming
only through Twitter from to clients I
see an opportunity potential with both
clients to expand and do more work and
I'll include those figures as they come
in very typically I'll work with a
client on one project and then expand to
do a lot more with them but you never
know what will happen or how many new
clients will also come in through
Twitter as it happens I will keep you
guys posted if you guys like this video
and you want to see more in the series
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear what you have to think
in the comments section I always read
them i loves him to come in so thank you
and i'll see you on the next episode
you
you